أريد أن أعطيكم هذه الأخبار العاجلة
التي صدرت للتو من واشنطن ، حيث
قام الرئيس الأمريكي دونالد ترامب
بتغريده للتو بأنه قد
أثبت أنه إيجابي للسرية ، وسوف أقرأها الليلة وأثبتت إصابتي
بالسرية 19. لقد كتب في  فقط
في اللحظات القليلة الماضية ، سنبدأ
عملية الحجر الصحي والتعافي على
الفور ، وسننتهي من ذلك
معًا مكتوبًا
بأحرف كبيرة ، وهذا بالطبع يأتي
بعد أن
تم اختبار أقرب مساعدة للرئيس إيجابية في الـ 24 ساعة الماضية ، ونحن
نفهم أنها تظهر عليها
الأعراض  وسوف نستمر في
مراقبة تقدمها ولكن من الواضح الآن أن كل الأنظار
قد أثبتت أن التركيز على الرئيس الأمريكي دونالد ترامب
إيجابي للسرية. أريد أن أذهب مباشرة إلى
طبيبنا د.
سوف أه
بشكل خاص على رجل في مثل
عمره بوزنه ، ما نوع المخاطرة التي
يواجهها الآن بشكل جيد روبن هذا إعلان مذهل
الليلة ونحن جميعًا  قلقون
بشأن اختبار أي شخص
للإصابة بالطمع ولكن على وجه الخصوص رئيس
الولايات المتحدة
والسيدة الأولى للولايات المتحدة ،
فهذا يوضح
مدى أهمية اختبار تتبع
أه الحجر الصحي والعزل
هنا ، يندرج الرئيس في فئة المخاطر العالية
التي يكبرها.  هو أه يعاني من زيادة الوزن إلى حد ما
أه لا أعرف عن أي حالات أخرى
موجودة مسبقًا أه قد يعاني منها أو
لا يعاني منها
ولكن المهم أنه
في فئة عمرية لديها
خطر الإصابة
بفيروس كوفيد -19  هذا مقلق للغاية